yes the iPhone 15 Pro Design has leaked
and yes this is the real deal this is
legitimate and I'll explain why in just
a minute but what people haven't really
been talking about is the cameras and
Apple's master plan with it according to
these cads which are from an actual case
maker now this does look very similar to
the current design that we have but it's
actually way different now this
exclusive leak is actually from Max
Weinbach who worked together with Ian
zelbo to create some amazing renders as
you can see right here we have the cad
and a nice wallpaper from basic apple
guy as you can see I'll show it just a
quick preview of these renders
absolutely amazing now before I really
dig deep into these cads the reason why
I believe this is the real deal is
because Max Weinbach was actually the
one to release the full CAD schematics
of the iPhone 14 pro and pro Max last
year back in March even though all of us
thought they would look completely
different with protruding flat glass on
the front and back with a completely
different layout those were wrong or at
least ahead of their time this was the
real deal and he was right that's why I
believe Max Weinbach is right with these
new ones as well now I've got to admit
that the renders that I made with
renders by Shailesh as you can see here
they are wrong they are completely wrong
because I assumed Apple would go with a
new design with protruding glass on the
back which is flat which is a
combination of leaks and rumors with
John Prosser's leaks as well so I kind
of combine them together and now this is
wrong especially the Periscope camera as
you can see right here shyles created
this my idea was that they would had a
fourth camera with a mirror Periscope
but that is also completely wrong and of
course that idea comes from Ming
shikwo's leak back in July of 2022
saying that the 15 Pro Max would get a
periscope lens with 6X magnification
which is awesome but of course as you
can see here is one of the cad design
renders from Ian zelbo the camera bump
is even more massive which means that
apple is not messing around it literally
is almost as thick as the phone itself
and here's actually a comparison from an
image Max sent to me personally on
Twitter that Ian Zelda created look at
the difference this is the 14 pro and
the 15 Pro it literally is wider
everything is larger and the camera
bumps themselves The lenses stick out
like crazy and the big question is how
is Apple going to leave a periscope 6X
lens with only three cameras it just
seems so weird well thankfully Sony has
that covered because Sony actually
invented an optical zoom lens and they
put it into the Xperia 1 mark IV as you
can see right here this is the Periscope
lens but it can actually zoom in and out
which is absolutely insane from 85
millimeters to 125 within the same
camera and you can actually see a little
clip of how this works right here check
this out
as you can see the lens element actually
moved back and forth magnetically so
true optical zoom and I believe that
apple is going to take this Tech and
create a 3X to 6X lens within this
triple camera design but wait that
actually wasn't the only thing that
leaked this past weekend of course we
have the insanely thin bezels which I'm
personally so excited for because I hate
thick bezels and the thinner they get
the better I love the phone so I'm super
excited but we have an even bigger leak
but before I get into that I've got to
talk about the best magsafe iPhone case
I've ever seen the magic stand case from
our partner case Q not only is it
surprisingly slim and durable but it
comes with a very strong 48 Magnet Max a
freeing that actually doubles as a stand
just pull out the ring to use it as a
finger grip or as a stand for watching
videos or anything else at an angle
between 40 and 120 degrees and the best
part is that it folds back completely
flush with the case so you can still use
it with your max save Chargers and
accessories so check out the link and
all the discount info in the video
description below and here it is the
bombshell leak that showed up as you can
see we have an image of the actual 15
Pro yes the actual 15 Pro and that right
there is a USB type-c port finally we're
getting rid of lightning and the slow
speeds for everything it's just so old
now USBC finally is coming and I'm
excited for it but the bigger deal we
can see is actually the Finish instead
of having glossy stainless steel sides
this right here is brushed titanium yes
that looks absolutely amazing and that's
not the only detail because you can see
that we have flat sides just like the
current iPhone 14 pro but they curve
around the sides and the edges right
there as you can see they curve towards
the glass so you're still going to be
able to put your iPhone upright like
this and have it balance and stand up
but there's also a curve so it's not
like the previous design of the iPhone 6
through 11 where it's curved all the way
throughout and rounded it's now also
flat and curved towards the sides just
like kind of like an apple watch now
this leak actually comes from u-reditor
on Twitter or unknowns 21 and this guy
knows his stuff because he also leaked
the code names and manufactured
codenames of the new iPhone lineup as
you can see iPhone 15 15 plus 15 Pro 15
Pro Max with the code names as well
which is absolutely amazing he even
knows which models are going to be
created or manufactured by AI wage
companies and Jessa confirmed some of
his other leaks he also leaked an
internal Apple document featuring the
antenna architecture and structure of
the new iPhone 15 Pro Models with Wi-Fi
6E so basically this guy has some
sources that are deep in the
manufacturing for Apple's iPhones now he
also believes that the ultra branding is
not going to be coming this year he
believes it's going to be the pro Max
just like Mark German said that the
ultra is not coming until next year with
the iPhone 16 lineup and apparently he
even has full resolution great images of
the entire iPhone he says he could even
do a close-up of a corner showcasing the
slight curve the bezel width case
difference apparently he has insane
access to these phones and then of
course we also have shrimp Apple Pro who
said he got a yes from his sources that
these cads are actually true you and
correct there are the real deal and
shrimp was actually the first one to
leak the dynamic Island so we definitely
trust him and he says that the display
design should be the same on the vanilla
15 as well with basically the same
design language he also said that the
actual weight of the 15 Pro is going to
go down by about 20 grams and that's
because titanium is lighter than the
current stainless steel just like what
we get with the Apple watches and here
Ian zobo even gave us some more behind
the scenes images of him creating new
renders as you can see we have this nice
brushed titanium texture which looks
absolutely amazing and of course we have
the textures of the USB type c port and
of course we know that the new iPhone 15
lineup is going to be going full on USBC
across the entire lineup however the two
high-end phones the 15 Pro and 15 Pro
Max will support higher or faster
transfer speeds hopefully Thunderbolt or
at least the faster versions of USBC
commit to very slow speeds on the
regular 15 and 15 plus which is very
unfortunate now Ian also gave us some
close-ups of the differences between the
14 pro and the 15 Pro as you can see we
have the 14 pro right here where it's
all flat all the way through with a nice
curve however the new model as you can
see 15 Pro is much more curved so it's
going to feel nicer in your hands and
you can actually see how the glass kind
of Curves into it now this is basically
called 2.5 D glass with shrimp Apple Pro
confirmed and as you can see the panel
is flat all the way through but then as
it gets close to the metal frame it
starts curving and Getting Thinner so it
creates a nice perfect subtle curve just
like we have on the Apple watches and
here's where it gets absolutely insane
in terms of cameras we have the iPhone
11 Pro on the left the first one to have
this etched glass camera bump then we
have the 14 pro and the 15 Pro the
camera bump is absolutely insane it just
sticks out so much now shrimp actually
gives some input on this sharing some
different renders right here as you can
see and this part sticks out like crazy
shrimp said that it has to be metal it
cannot be plastic because if you drop
your phone it is going to crack and I
agree I believe this is also gonna be
metal on the end as well and finally
I've got to talk about the significance
of this massive camera change Apple is
not stopping people thought that the
camera bump on the 14 pro was insane I
can't believe they made it this big but
they're making it even bigger which
means camera quality is everything for
Apple that is the ultimate goal and they
do not care how big their camera bump
has to get to improve the camera quality
now the reason these bumps are so big is
because apple is likely putting in much
better cameras in terms of the actual
sensors so they're probably putting in
larger sensors which require the lenses
to be longer to accommodate the bigger
sensors now that doesn't mean they have
to change from 12 megapixels on some of
them to higher resolutions they could
actually keep 12 megapixels but just
make the sensor size itself larger which
basically increases the amount of light
that comes in which is going to help a
ton for low light photography and in
general just make them look a lot better
that is the goal that it looks like from
Apple that's the master plan and then of
course a longer lens helps with a
periscope zoom lens and that'll help
Apple be able to create a 3x to 6X
Periscope much more easily because they
have more internal space so that way
they can keep this triple camera bump
layout the same without having to add an
additional fourth camera I think apple
is gonna blow it out of the park this
year and start dominating the
competition because the competition is
scared of making massive camera bumps
but apple is not so with that said let
me know your thoughts down in the
comment section below definitely
subscribe for more videos like this one
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video
[Music]
foreign